our friend Jeff Passan broke that
baseball and the Players Association are
focusing on a pine backed by a federal
health officials that could have could
have players in training camps by May
and games soon thereafter and he was
kind enough to call on the show to put a
little bit more of meat on those bones
how are you Jeff I am well rich how are
you I'm glad to hear that so um how real
is this plan about I guess creating
their own bubble world to use or bubble
city bubble state and to use that guess
the Cuban phrase of what the NBA might
be considering yeah at this point it's
not terribly realistic because there are
so many logistical hoops that they need
to jump through the first thing that
they would need to do is get players on
board and strike some sort of a deal
between the players and the league in
order to start going ahead and making
plans how many rooms do we need how many
people do we need to make food how many
people do we need drive buses where do
we find these people out early
background check them I mean there are
like I say a million things there are
thousands of things that need to be done
before this happens but the feeling
among some people inside the sport right
now is that this is the best hope for
getting baseball on the field this year
now as Major League Baseball said in a
statement earlier today there are other
options out there but most of those
options involve waiting and as we know
and as we've seen in many regards with
Sports one weight turns into a much
longer one and when you have a date in
mind it typically gets pushed back when
you do something like this biodome
situation the dates are immaterial
because the sanctity of the dome is what
is supposed to keep you and those around
you and those on the outside safe and
healthy and if they can get buy-in from
players to do that which is gonna be
really really hard to do I think the
thing at very least has a chance of
moving forward and at least seeing the
logistical capabilities whether they can
pull that off well I guess then again it
is it is something you just show it
about when we're like hey sports
shouldn't is going to have to return you
just went through and it's you
if you do get all the players on board
as you point out the logistics aspect
where do they stay how clean how can
they how can they guarantee the
cleanliness or the covert 19 freeness of
all of that and all it takes is one
person who drove the bus to break their
own containment because because and and
makes sense that a family member needs
to come to their house for something and
that person ran into another person who
had covin 19 now all of a sudden an
entire major league club gets exposed
through all of that I cannot imagine how
to figure all that out where where is
the I guess push of this coming from was
it maybe from a call with the president
over the weekend with all of the
commissioners Jeff no no this is
something that predates that call by a
couple of weeks now and there there have
been some federal health officials who
have been strongly in favor of this plan
and listen they they have their own
motivations right I think that they see
baseball as sort of an opportunity to
reopen the country now is a premature it
might be and is the the possibility of
baseball not being able to do this
realistic yes very like if they pull
this thing off
it will it will be an incredible this
thing off and they pull it off with the
support of the players and they pull it
off and can somehow keep everyone
healthy and keep everybody inside the
biodome and get buy-in from everyone it
will be a an unbelievable feat that
being said if that is the best option
that they've got right now and players
recognize that the only way I get paid
in 2020 is if I play baseball games well
they want to play baseball games and the
the you know as crazy as some of the
elements of this are rich and I fully
acknowledge they are bonkers the
motivations of players to get paid and
of owners to make money are very very
strong Jeff Passan
ESPN MLB and Sardar here on the Rich
Eisen show so again clearly something
you know we've got a plan ahead people
have to plan ahead again at the end of
May or the beginning of June there may
be better contact tracing in the United
States there may be a better way for
everybody to know who's had it or who
has it and thus those who've had it are
able to do stuff like go outdoors and
those who have it are the ones who are
put inside not the entire population so
it is possible that we plan for these
moments that conditions as they are now
when it is better we can pull that out
of the front drawer and actually do it
so what are correct so what with social
distancing obviously still needing to
take place what what might fans need to
know about how baseball or the plans for
this would go I guess where the players
are all together and trying to maintain
their their health in a sport where
everybody's in a dugout etc and so on
and so forth now there's a possibility
rates that everybody's not in the dugout
there's possibility that in order to
model social distancing for the general
public who are going to be watching
these games on television that we're
going to see players sitting in the
stand six feet apart that that's part of
I think the government push here and and
why health officials see baseball which
is a sport that typically socially
distances pretty naturally as being
archetypal in coming back now between
that and in the idea of an electronic
strike zone so that the umpire doesn't
have to hover over the catcher and you
know base coach is standing even further
back than they typically would I mean
they're they're a bunch of little things
that can be done but what they preach
also has to be practiced like inside the
clubhouses you're not going to have like
a bunch of you know grab-assing going on
my god that just can't that can't be
part of this whole thing it just can't
in order for it to work even if you are
inside the biodome even if you are clean
it's like you got a
you know the way one person described it
to me is for something like this to work
baseball players need to look at
themselves as a little less baseball
player and a little more Armed Forces
member and and that is in the discipline
that they would need to do this whether
it's following the rules that are put
into place by public health officials or
doing something as simple as knowing
that for the next you know indefinite
period of time you're not gonna be able
to go out and like grab a meal drink a
beer meet up with a friend hang out with
a girl none of those things are on the
table anymore
and and what you're getting for this is
painful number one you're getting paid
for it
number two you're becoming part of the
first wave of people to be back in the
first sport to be back in America and
number three you could potentially be
doing a service to baseball and setting
it up long term because it's baseball
rich is this first sport back if it's
got the national attention this is
something that could be incredible for
the for the long-term health of the
sport and I think that people in the
game recognize that and if they can't
want to take advantage to become if you
will Nash the national pastime once
again right yeah no question about it
and I think that appeals to people but
they don't want to get too far out over
their skis here and and that's why the
idea that this is going to be rushed
into place I think is pretty optimistic
but if they land you know this week is
gonna be an important week the players
and MLB are going to be talking they're
going to be talking then the
alternatives and they're gonna see if
they can get together on the economics
of this and if they can get together on
the economics and all of a sudden you
know there's a fighting chance for this
plan and and so that's this week is what
you're saying
again it's not like that because you do
have to plan for in case you know the
virus timeline does actually allow for
something like this right sure
absolutely and and they you know MLB in
the
in the union had conversations yesterday
I think you're gonna you're gonna really
start here and from some players and
their feelings on the situation and
typically the the players who were going
to be speaking out are the ones who were
going to be against this but you know
I've gotten let's put it this way I've
heard from a number of players and there
have been a pretty wide variance of
opinions one guy who I talked with who
said no way he would do it and then he
talked with his wife and he said okay I
guess I'll do it this is the only way
you're getting paid go do it
like I can I could deal with it yeah
another player who essentially was
saying yeah this sounds like an okay
idea but are we really going to ask
baseball players to be in quarantine for
potentially months and playing 120
degree heat in Phoenix to game that
because some of the changes might not
look particularly familiar totally
reasonable point and then I heard from
another player who said I want to get
paid I'll do whatever they want me to
and what was that running the gamut as
you would say okay Jeff thanks the call
appreciate it I know you got more to do
really appreciate your time thank you
pleasure is always my my friend actually
thanks to the call that's just passing
to me as PN